gorgeous gorgeous yes i made this during
the commercial break uh we're back here
with martha stewart who's going to show
me uh first how to make some
holiday eggnog a real thing the real
thing a real thing so we have
two quarts of milk cold milk cold milk
and we have about a cup and a half of
sugar that's dissolved and we have
16 egg yolks 16 egg yolks 16 and then we
add
2 cups of heavy cream great and then the
cholesterol
learning drug lipitor i think grind it
up and just sprinkle that in there
a rest oh my god look at that i like to
do three different kinds of liquors in
it because i just love the taste
first of rum rum yeah so
put in about a cup of rum a cup of rum
okay
sweet rum all right and then a cup of
bourbon
okay cup of bourbon that's that's two
cups that's cheap
because i'm really sure i'll do
incompetent all right thank you
and then i honestly didn't know that was
two cups that shows you where i've been
okay one cup or two cups of one cup one
cup okay all right well
and then and then
um and then i like cognac in it too
sweet cognac
one cup of this and your guests will be
very
happy and this is this is a fresh nutmeg
you have to have fresh nutmeg
oh my god oh come on yum
that is really good nutmeg and then
i always stretch before i drink
and then dollops of whipped cream
whipped cream look at that whipped cream
heavy cream
16 egg yolks my god this is it
yeah this is it and you should enjoy
because you'll have a heart attack in an
hour every single little bit of you have
defibrillating paddles when you do this
okay and then do you mix the heavy cream
in or you're literally no no no no
okay i mean this is very special now you
take a little bit of the
the liquid get the shakes and now you
have a you why
you haven't even had anything relax
usually drunk by now okay mmm
what do you think creamy
okay it's very good it's very good it's
excellent
it's it's fine are you going to have a
headache uh yeah but who cares
if you drink enough you uh you actually
pass out and you're unconscious for the
headache part i found
oh delicious it's very nice and then
with with this of course you want to
have roasted chestnuts
yes and you want to decorate your tree
let's go let's go decorate the trees
this is all about this is all about like
christmas eve or
in america it's about december 1st this
is what my
living room looks like by the way this
is an exact replica of my living room
yes
you have an oriental carpet yes and i
have a linoleum floor and then there's
an audience right there
all these beautiful ornaments and you
know where these all come from right uh
these probably come from
marthastewart.org.com
no no these come from kmart kmart oh
kmart of course i'm sorry
martha stewart everyday ornaments at
kmart these are very nice
look at this and they're really
inexpensive and very beautiful and you
can
you can do this whole tree for about 599
dollars
599 that sounds like a bargain
go like his comment conan go like this
oh oh sorry okay
all right so these are great do you hang
these different corners here are these
men you know
do we have what goes on top we have a
little star here fabulous thing where is
that
no i have no idea oh here it is the tree
topper you have to have a tree topper
and conan has a very special one look
a little carrot topped tree topper wait
put a little phone in get in there tight
look at that little angel cook that
that's incredible you had that specially
made
i did it's me as a little girl
this is very nice martha we're very
tight on time i think we should move
over to the
roasting the nuts part of the uh evening
here you want to roast some nuts
huh yeah oh yeah oh this is the actual
i've seen these when you like go and
visit a
museum don't try to scramble eggs in
this okay okay no these are these are
brand new you don't get these in a
museum
okay and these are the chestnuts that
you please don't scream at me again you
have pierced
you have pierced that's right so here
hold that and we hold these over some
oh wait you just have to make sure that
you use a sharp little knife this is a
special knife for piercing chestnuts
and you just make sure you make an x in
the bottom because you don't want the
chestnut
heaven forbid to split so you can't use
a regular knife it must be
a chestnut cutting knife yes or this is
another solution just use a beer can
opener
and i like that just it makes that i
have yes i know so you just go like that
see
very nice okay so you need to split it
okay okay so you roast those in the fire
yes and i don't want to stand too close
to this roaring fire right here
you can just put it down on the heart
just put it down on the hearth right
there yeah but
uh sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
okay
yes okay the 60 watt bulb in that fire
burned me so here i have a chestnut and
then we sit and you sit and you
and you and you sing chess
a little band please
[Music]
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
being
[Applause]
merry christmas
you